welcome to how to build studying data
science web applications in Python with
typod I'd like to introduce our speakers
the founder of timepai Vincent Goslin
and Florin Jack the at the end we'll
have a short q a session
hi everybody
is like 10 months old
um
we are a little bit different from the
usual startup in other words
we are former Gamers we were building
launch application AI application mostly
for large companies and inside it a few
years back to move everything
then we realized there were some issues
with python and situation of pipeline
so
um
where we come from is really
applications where you close your data
scientists but you also have people
using the algorithm from the Amazon
point of view
so that's why we use this term also
decision support systems so in other
words type I has been designed to design
relief or a very wide range of
application
so I'll talk to you about Ai and so on
but it can be used for dashboarding all
the way to more complex systems
including AI
operation research mathematical
optimization simulation also so that's
also
the objective of State Bank
one thing again that we take into
account is the need of end users to a
fund we hear about the data scientists a
lot of stuff for the data scientists but
you need to development application for
end user this may explain also why
python is also having such a low rate of
conversion from Pilot
we know a lot of applications on that
it started as a python pilot and being
Rewritten completely into other
languages this is not sustainable you
absolutely need to know the full circle
here and that requires to go beyond only
the
Realm of the data sound system to think
also in terms of an exist
well that's also something that we we
bring here with with
so these are some of the data that you
can get from gapner so 85 percent of the
Python Pilots State Pilots you know and
there are many reasons for it it's
mainly because first there is no Roi the
bike
so yes sorry
thank you
you miss much
that's what you missed I guess
why didn't you say anything
[Music]
we'll give you a free license it's open
source
okay so that I talked about
that's where we are right now
so
yeah so again again that's that's uh the
reason for for having created a Titan
um
Taipei was also created with large
company right from the start so the
software has been used by McDonald's
companies like Samsung like large
retailers
so we don't want to build the product
without having end users on people
data scientists to participate to the
creation so this is one of the the
application here showing also the
interest of developing with a product
like like ours
so this is an I.T Department in one of
the largest retailer in Europe
and the option was actually to go for a
tender for 600k to develop a forecast
for their cash flow so it's a
the new the end users were the CFO and
the treasures for this company
so it was costing them 600k for people
eight months to get their first release
the very same thing was developed 60k
1.5 percent okay so in two months so
basically cost twice it's a factor 10.
that's also one of the objectives that
you want to achieve
with uh
this kind of
package
so
type I we call it a platform because it
covers two elements the graphical side
on the backhand side
and you will see also I will talk about
the roadmap you will see also in the
future these two will come together
this is typically python package you do
keep install type I and you've got I5
installed in a few seconds
so maybe a little bit more about
why again we came into developing a
content and so many content
offer and also the back end and the
pipeline so
on the front end we really look at what
was available so you've got a lot of
great widget libraries
and so on so forth but these are widget
okay it doesn't make a full application
with the user highly interactive a
multi-page and so on and so forth
so that's that was not what we wanted of
course you can always build with totally
uh TK enter all of this but you need to
be a specialist
a green specialist
or a JavaScript specialist we do not
want that we want type I to be usable by
any data scientist any python developer
and to have a learning curve which is
very fast at the same time we want power
we want the capability to customize or
to have good performance
there's one tool we looked at called
stream knit but we felt miserably on
real application this is a tool again
fantastic for Pilots but come up scope
one thing wanted also for what type I
was really to be able to run on Python
scripts I mean normal python code
basically as well as notebooks
so you will see who we are going to show
you at the end I think we'll use collab
full blown application for python
notebooks for the first time you will
see that this doesn't exist really at
the moment
okay we are the only one to to do that
and the backhand side so again we looked
at what was available
and we saw a whole range of offers which
were either white or
complexion curve
and a lot of missing features but we
thought were really needed in the
context of the application I talked to
you about
so it's not about again short learning
curve I don't want people to learn
for years that particular tool to become
Specialists you need to you must be able
to design a
pipeline easily and execute them easily
without
uh you know with with a few within a few
hours
we look at things like what if analysis
scenario management we didn't find
anything available
your data lineage and so on but there's
nothing really for for python so we did
go into this
we're going to Cycles so Cycles are when
you work for McDonald for instance every
week they need to produce for every
single store a forecaster sales forecast
different forecasts for different
products
so there's a weekly cycle here some
other customers might be up on a monthly
basis in other Industries
or hourly so you have this kind of cycle
so you need to be able to run your
experience experience or your runs or
executions and uh to basically solve
them by time brackets like this
like this okay and to say you know
within that week this is the official
scenario so all the scenario management
was also not really available anyway
all of this is to explain that uh why we
created a type by code
so I'll stop it here I will hand over to
Florida we will show you some code
so be careful when we mention the word
local
it's always on videos okay for uh
it's not really low code to the point
where most python developers will run
away
um you you have to code but it
it's important that you you see at which
level so this is what we're going to
show you and after that I'll come back
and I will show you some of the roadmap
that we have on the new products around
type Island who will be launching soon
thank you
foreign
yeah just to explain to you we have a
problem we want to minimize the cost of
uh like production
so we have a lot of constraints that we
can move to create different models to
solve different problems and then
everything we can see it's here on this
space so here is like two three
solutions that we have of our problem we
can change these different solutions to
see what is the best solution of our
product with different constraints
changing into graph
just to show you how attractive it is I
would like some kind of application
Gateway with type 5 so now that you see
how they look like you just means you go
to the code and how we can create your
first application with type item
[Music]
for all the pipelines but normally you
just use type I as a wall so you just
click install type 5 and you will be
able to use it
and this is article that I have created
to show you how you can create the first
application
so I have clip install type 5 and I'm
just importing now the GUI element
and in this way I'm going to put a
string in it so this string I will have
this melody syntax bottom here
um so the goal is to just type uh our
text for example type idea here will it
be titled in a web page and so on so I
can also do this okay so this is
building so I have one line which is
important this string here and then I'm
going to put this page into my green and
run it
so let's do that I'm just going to run
my grid and we will see our web page uh
I will descriptive
design and now I have the page here
so I'm just going to put it here
and okay so I have just my page now done
type ID mode type 180 is a title demo
isn't it so this is the login syntax
so obviously it's not really interesting
here because I can't really do anything
on my web page so I'm just going to
create
um elements so when we say normally
instead I agree is the normal version of
Madan so we're just going to add to this
modern syntax type a user elements
and they always have the same symptoms
so for example if I want to show my w
here which is 10 like a pattern object
I'm just going to uh this syntax what
you see here so inferior band pipe my
button viable what I want to see or what
I want to display to modify and sound
and then the name on my visual element
when I want to show here will be text so
I just want to show text like a tank
here so I'm just going to save it
and I'm going to show you the results so
we'll normally add value then
like this value thing
nice but of course the application yes
so this is the next step I'm going to
show you so we are going now to create a
slider
so this slider is also going to identify
my value so this is my buy that variable
again and this is the element name so
elements that I'm going to use cider
just make two edit
and then refresh and we will have
outside there just next to this
so the slider uh with the text and what
is really interesting with type 5 is
that if I'm going to change my slider
it's also going to change my text so
this is automatic biting between two of
the elements you don't have to do
anything I have to write callbacks and
so on type I will take care of this
alternating binding between elements so
I'm just changing this it's changing my
text automatically
um so next well uh what we want normally
to have is like charts like we want to
realize some data so I'm just going to
create some data which I'm just going to
take function here
a very simple function
that will create a cosine list so
if I can do
so these functions will create like a
list of cosine that we Decay at a time
so just to show some data
and I will put it into
an iPhone object data now I want to show
it on my Wii so what I have to do is
create a visual element
so like this
some data
depend charts also you see that I have
some Auto completion like this so this
is type A Studio this is a vs code
extension that we have created for type
5 I will just tell you what uh what like
values you can have for your user
elements so this year what you see is
all these zero elements that we have
some button chart dialogue is connected
my dates are
in a chart I'm just going to
refresh
and we'll grab it here
um so we have this cosine that we have a
time it's also interactive so I can zoom
in zoom out if you know partly in fact
we are based on plotly for the charts so
you have all the types of battery and if
I can show you like another
Communications you can go here
called Zoe elements so these are all the
episodes we have so button includes our
sliders so a lot of things and if I go
to the Chart you have like all the
details all the examples that you need
to create for yourself so bar charts
iron shots uh field errors eye charts
answer with 13 betin
my data
but for now uh we don't actually use
something that is really attractive
which is being changed by my seller
maybe it would be great if I'm changing
this slider it's also going to change my
charts so let's do this I'm going to
create a callback so
I'm going to say unchanged
of course to uh some functionality.net
so it tells me that I happen to create
my functions I'm going to create a
function here
let's go like this so what type I will
do here so I must either I have this
parameter unchanged uh what it means it
means that what I'm going to change my
value of my starter is going to call
this function but I have not created yet
directly so I'm changing my center it's
a couple of function and I have to
implement the logic behind it
um the parameter that is passed to this
function is the states
type is not user by Design so it means
that you have different states for
different users another two different
things
so now we need to change the state of my
data depending on the state of my value
so generator depending on the Strider so
this is what you see here state.data
equals compute data the good value
and like this you have created the
Callback on a slider this is going to
change your chart dynamically
so I'm doing this
the other side there and I'm changing my
side door here it's going to call this
function I'm going to change the data
basically this
so if you think it's a bit too complex
for you well in fact you can just delete
everything here
and if you know a bit about like the
Upstream formats
well this is kind of the same thing you
can input actual python expression into
your visual element so I'm just going to
put directly this function with W in it
and now I don't have to write callbacks
anymore just saying this will work
what happens is that type I will know
that you have changed your slider so
your value and it will recalculate the
text that also means python expression
with config data
and you have the same behavior so this
is why we say it is low code so you
don't have to write a lot of things the
callbacks with just like 20 lines I've
created the application with the slider
text and a channel this uh dynamically
Changed by singular
so this is business contact by the way
you have this kind of syntax and I can
create a bigger application like extramu
with it's a production problem and it's
always a syntax with this is all
elements
um also I'm going to just show you a bit
about the feature will be adding type
which is called the decimator
so this generator is for a large data
sometimes you want to show millions of
points like you have the data points but
it can't really show it uh in a Content
application like this so one point yeah
sorry so what you'll do is you will use
the decimator so the symmeter is like a
property but you put on a chart in order
to filter the data in order to
um to like at least multiply the shape
of the curve so for example if I
obtaining those coins for line charts I
want to just be able to see it in agree
estimator
[Music]
and here
so I'm going to filter the data to just
show uh like a few points but you can
you will be able to show it uh in an
integral episode this is like the data
without decimator I'll just leave it
like not millions of course because I
want to be able to sit here and this is
web installator so you see I have a few
points but I have my shape on my
preserved this can served but also when
you're going to zoom in on your curve
we're going to repopulate the points
so now you can use like a big data like
launch data into your application using
the destinator for example so we have a
lot of features like this Inside by
making it about you to do like large
data and uh decide because I will
produce for example from source
to 500 points yeah so um it removes all
the points at least modify the shape of
the curve
it's still populated we have 500 points
Zoom again
and it works also with cluster grad so
it's not only for Time series
just to add to the graphics also because
performance is a very important thing
and
we are not covering everything here give
you some example sometimes you have a
long run an only diffusion you don't
want to be stuck with your graphics
waiting for the run so you have to have
the capability to say you know this is a
synchronous core or asynchronous it's
asynchronous then you can go about your
graphics and wait for the long run to
finish okay so you get all these
capabilities to tune and to look at
performance and having nice behaviors
okay so this is what we bring also with
I buy but we cannot cover everything
is also the refreshing right sometimes
if you work with a platform like codab
and you get the graphics locally on your
machine and you have refresh rate which
needs to be customized because it's not
local to your to your own machine so you
get a lot of stuff like that to make it
really a nice experience for for data
scientists but I'm also for getting user
so what I've shown to you is my baby so
just how you can create an interface but
what we want to do with type is to be
able to create Pilots but also
applications for applications with all
the data like for example if you are in
a AI environment you maybe want to do
like some training some tasting
Innovation also in your application so
this is why we also provide fi coil that
for you to manage paid plans manage your
data easily with type 5. what you see
here is that I call
we have here just an MS Pipeline with
some cleaning data so we clean the data
with this operation evaluation
and if it's this is not just a
visualization visualizer of my pipeline
this is step by Studio it's a vs code
extension that's where I've created
another two this is the pipeline but
also to edit it so I can go here and
like change my details of my pipeline
but before right I'm just going to like
uh make sure like just listen to you
what it is so what you see here uh like
the blue boxes are what we call data
notes
so this is pointer to all data for
example here the initial data set is a
CSV in fact so if I go to the details it
would be able to see it so it's a CSV
with some app so just to point out to my
data this is data set could also have
been like this SQL and and Excel
Json anything we just point to the data
and we will be able to use it in type 5.
so this is a CSV and then we're going to
use vcsd in some tasks so the orange
boxes are tests this is just the
translation of Python's functions into
type I so this if I receive the details
again we have inputs outputs but the
function that I'm using is inside a
python function that I've created so
just function clean data which is here
so I am creating this Pipeline with my
data node so with CSV or Json or
anything
and then
good all right so with this different
types of data sources and then we're
doing some tests on it and I guess you
intuate your tasks your data nodes your
pipelines and then you will be able to
use it in your python code this is all
of this what you see is just
configuration
I'm just configuring my data I'm just
copying my pipelines and then I will be
able to use it it's kind of a class
pattern when you are going to create
instances of this class
but maybe one thing to add on the data
Note just to make sure
it's not only data coming from the
outside it could be like here for
instance you notice you've got daily
it's actually a date okay so that's a
python object
so it could come from the graphics or
something at somewhere else okay so it
goes beyond just data from the outside
again we're thinking of
in this particular example
this is the parameter we'll be changing
um two different ones where but Royal
will be
doing some variation by changing the day
so in this particular example that's the
date from which you want to predict
okay so this anode goes it's anything
that can be an input or not put to a
task to a Java function basically
sorry the python function
it's like all this configuration that
you have done
uh you can do it perfectly with that by
Studio or you can do it with just python
so it can also be a way to do it if you
are like a for Loop you have like a lot
of pipelines interact with python but it
will be the same way so you got data
nodes with a CSV here the path
also this is a scope so it's like a type
concept it just means that this they
cannot air initial data set will be shut
by every pipelines every scenario so a
scenario is just a virtual part time so
it will be shot by everything
and for example the days of the day of
prediction or the one that will be going
to change between each one will unlock
news code the default is scenario so I'm
going to create an instance of this
configuration and each scenario will
have a different date of operation so
just a way to manage our visual data
between different pipelines different
scenarios
so you have lots of features like this
but I'm going just to go to the limited
and what it does
um I'm importing this configuration that
I've done because if it's like this this
position it's just
um a tunnel file right behind it is
something like this
then we're just going to interact with
it with this graphical editor
so I'm importing this configuration that
I've done with this scenario so this
pipeline
and then I'm going to be able to create
two instances of this configuration so
this is what I'm doing here
I have create scenario based on this
configuration so an instance of this
configuration with some name
and then you will be able to change your
data node like this so
if I want to change my day of prediction
what I will do is scenario dot day my
data node that I want to change that's
right my dates my new date
and this syntax is always the same so if
you are like an SQL CSV Excel like data
you will also have like scenario.white
so it really simplifies the way you
interact with your data uh with type I
and then when I'm when I've changed my
day I'm just going to submit my scenario
which just means that I'm going to run
off my pipelines all of my tasks and in
15 minutes in parallel it will be very
power to make it really more efficient
less responses and less time to to
execute it
yeah so of course there are some
Saturdays here when you're in
development mode the last thing you want
is to run your pipeline in color you
want to follow what the pipeline
executes so there are different mode of
working and in development it will be
one task at a time so that you can
follow them when you start to move into
uh
staging or deep production then you want
to have a parallelism if it can be
achieved
so here in this function I have changed
my scenario I estimate it and so this is
what happens here I'm just going to make
some audience a minute using instruction
of electron you and if I want to read my
data node how can I do it well it's
almost the same thing we have
scenio.line dot minded that's really
enabled information but uh is in my
detail so again can we just be an
external SQL mongodb anything you can
read this information like this just
with this syntax
it doesn't change
here what you see is just to for example
I have a full loop I will just create
tensionals for me automatically normally
you would do it with type way so you
have this sort of phase where you change
your parameters then click on new
scenario you click on submit and so on
so it will be not like practically so
here I'm just going to show you the
create your create a scenario and
execute it yeah
and then you have a lot of python type
functions in order to navigate your data
analysis scenarios uh to yeah will you
do a lot of things to manipulate what
you have done with a pipeline so this
function here just meant to get all of
my scenarios that I've created
all of myself what I've created uh it
will put it in a list and then I'm going
to just read evaluation so just the
results of my pipeline
metrics
I'm going to execute it
and we'll see what happens
so it's creating all of my scenarios
there
so tense and iOS
mn3 integrates my typical application
will show my metrics
so very easy to integrate type
everywhere but what I wanted to show
but it is either in the logs it's not
for my first scenario
so this is my personality I am free task
I have to clean uh the predict and
evaluate okay
so for my cleaning sorry yeah so what
you see here is my pistonio and the jobs
related to this task so the clean data
has been completed
uh the predicting has been completed and
evaluation also completed and if I go to
my second scenario where I have created
and submitted you will see that the
clean data here is being skipped which
means that type will not do your task it
will just skip your task
but the other one will be completed so
why
well if we go here
we see that what I have changed between
all of my scenarios is the day of
prediction I haven't changed the initial
data set so if I trade like a lot of
scenarios next two minutes
is a function will always give me the
same results
it's not fully useful and it takes a lot
of resources for nothing so I'm just
going to skip this task so paper can do
it automatically if you have said that
this task can be capable so just go here
if it's not really useful to do it again
and again and again for each scenario
so we have a lot of features like this
to make it more efficient in the state
play core so it can be run parallel you
have this copying mechanism you have
this capability also mechanism
together you can put petition but I
efficient powerful
um like that can be put in different
production
yeah so one thing just to finish on the
pipelines we have also a version
interview
for instance we have customers again
that have generated hundreds if not
thousands of scenarios over time
and suddenly your pipeline
modified is modified you have a new data
source a new parameter and you can't see
or you can't do anything with the past
scenarios
so everybody talks about machine
learning
models that are basically version right
most equality Pipelines
nothing
okay so that's a bit of a problem
so you have we address that with type 5
it has capability to have different
versions and also to migrate past ROMs
to work still work with your new
Pipelines
okay so this is a something also that uh
it's not very sexy to show by the way
but very useful very important
so what I'll do now I'll show you
quickly the roadmap we have and also
I'll try to run the graphical interface
here by IPI with type by and collab
foreign
okay
thank you
okay so let's go back to this um
presentation so
the next phrase importance release for
type by will be in June on the graphical
side I'm starting with the graphics
um we have a GUI preview capability like
a previewer so while you are designing
and building your web your pages
basically using not extended countdown
you will see
the layout appear while you're coming
okay in power
okay so that's something that will be uh
quite interesting we'll have better
tables all our tables are editable and
they're quite nice but we wanted to go
one step further with the word indexing
if you've got thing and all this that
will be part of the next release
uh we have a default study I mean there
are a lot of people like me I guess who
don't like to touch and do anything
related with CSS stuff so we have
probably need some uh style sheets by
default and you can customize it very
easily that's already a very good idea
that's part of the camera's release type
I core so this is where we will bring
the GUI and the core together where we
will provide graphical components to
visualize a scenario with with its data
load or this task so you'll be able to
query the data itself so all of this
will come like a graphical component
that will potentially make the
development even faster
and we are launching type iCloud next
week so for those of you interested who
will that will be free also will be able
to
basically upload your application to the
machine so we have some
um
example of what it will look like so you
can choose which machine of course we
will not provide you with super duper
machines over there but you'll be able
to run your diaper application over
there it will zip uh your files and you
will be able to deploy it for the
capability to
look at the usage of the machines
okay
so that's uh on the offer on the last
thing I want to show you
um yeah just just before I go
we have a repo so have a look and
contribute if you want
uh give us a story if you if you really
want
the thing I will show you now is
collapse so what I've done here I've
already loaded
basically the
I've installed
Transformers type by and audio so I'll
talk about engineer work later but I buy
immediate here and Transformers because
we're using some
again face
[Music]
model over there so once we have done
that we have loaded the model we are
going to run
um
the first page so we have built
the first type by Page
okay so it's being loaded now there is a
second page that has been developed here
by the week
and then you can see here the last cell
is actually
the root page which is the page you will
be landing and it it's made of two
components the first page I've uploaded
on the second page that's uploaded
earlier okay and I'm going to run this
on a remote platform I mean it's not
running on jupitable books here it's
running a remote platform
okay come on running this
okay I'm going to click on this goes to
both sides
okay so it's redirecting basically you
have a URL that shows the the graphics
of that
remote platform here collateral and you
have access to your graphics multiple
page
here
how much you can play with it so here
it's just a sentiment analysis thing
so
you can analyze it and you will see that
it's working you can do the text and so
on and so forth okay so you can really
have a multi-page
fairly sophisticated graphic
from another book platform
okay
okay that's all
[Applause]
[Music]